good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast
[Music]
and
B wow that's a really really crazy way
to start
Friday gotta get down on Friday
everybody is looking forward to the
weekend weekend not only are we looking
forward to the weekend we're looking
forward to the long ass weekend so like
let this episode
rain positivity rain
Joy did you see the video recently of
Rebecca Black performing Friday at a
concert in like Melbourne and she did
you seriously just ask me that question
of course I've seen that video we
haven't discussed it and I'm pretty sure
I posted it and I tagged you and you
didn't like respond to that cuz we send
a million things back and forth like we
never discussed it she kind of like just
remixed it she kind of ate that [__] up
I was going to say she kind of ate one
thing Rebecca Black is going to do is
she she's going to eat that song in
particular and she's always putting a
new spin on it based on whatever era
she's in sometimes she goes through like
a kind of um EDM phase and she released
like an EDM version then she's like in
like a more of a rocker element Punk
Vibe so she does that wherever the kind
of the wind takes Rebecca Black she
takes that song with her it's a great
career move for her I I really I think
it's solid I think it's solid as well I
did see the video I'm so glad you
brought it up I'm so excited to be doing
this show with you I'm we're we're an
international show and now I I know we
always say that as a joke because we
have like 11 followers in Canada but we
actually are international right now
because I'm out of Z I am in Mexico H
EST
L
isy tury sitting in front of a surfboard
is that your surfboard you plan on
surfing yes this is my surfboard I'm in
my hotel room I brought my equipment um
the decor is very uh
shall I say nautical yeah so that
explains the surfboard behind me I'm
headed to the beach right after this
just looking to soak in some some sun
you know
actually Ben is
golfing shocker which is so crazy like
to golf on vacation but did he bring his
clubs to Mexico so he didn't bring his
clubs but he's going straight from
Mexico to La for work and he always
brings golf clothes to LA because I
guess that's like how you do business is
you golf I don't know that makes a
little sense so he has like his whole
get up outfit but he doesn't have clubs
but the guys that he's golfing with like
nobody brings their clubs down to Mexico
so they're all just going to run and
it's not like a serious game it's just
like for fun okay okay cool cool so I'm
going to podcast head to the beach read
my romance novel and you know take some
time for myself before the Weekend
begins love that make sure you wear
sunscreen like well I got a spray T
important I got a spray tan so like I
will be sitting in the shade oh that's
good too yeah yeah yeah
it's just time to start staying out of
the sun oh I agree like women of a
certain age yeah it's time for that I
completely
agree well I'm glad you're practicing
skin health and what are you doing this
weekend while I'm in Mexico I have some
fun little plans I'll be in and around
the neighborhood having fun seeing
friends having play
dates so cute so cute maybe I'll cook a
little something something because my
cigar Wheels I'm off on we myar Wheels
my meals they don't send me meals for
the weekend so I'm on my own I like that
I like it too and it's a good way for me
to try and stay on a decent program but
also if like I was craving something
during the week I can have it over the
weekend I could make if I wanted a chili
let me ask you a question when Harry has
a play date like obviously I know what
my experience is because I'm kind of the
number one play date date but when Harry
has a play date like with a friend like
what do they get
into it depends on the age of of the
friend if it's someone his own age it's
kind of like parallel play a little bit
unless they like know each other really
well but if if it's just like me hanging
out with someone and then like their kid
comes to how doesn't like know him it's
like it's parallel play a little bit but
then sometimes when he's playing with
older kids and if it's like a group of
kids and they have a thing going you
know cu the older kids know how to play
like he kind of just inserts himself
into that like the other day he learned
how to play duck duck goose stop are
kids still playing that game these kids
were hot take that's like not a fun
game it was cute to watch I I didn't
hate it you know what's not a fun game
what tag Red Rover well that game is
like violent it is violent and unsafe I
agree I never liked it as a kid like you
would love to be the one like running
but you never wanted to be the one who's
hand was about to get broken hand broken
yeah I agree some of those games like
age well some of them don't Red Rover
Red Rover send tur R over is definitely
one of the worst games also tag your it
is like such a it's a game like without
out rules like I think it's a bad
game yeah it's little all over the place
doesn't have much structure structure a
good game you know what's a good game
Hide and Seek yes oh what's like the
hide and seek like on
crack is it called like
sardines I'm not no no Jackie we used to
play with our cousins and like when it
went right it was really right like
everyone would hide around the house
somebody would have to find some or no
like you would find the person and then
you'd have to hide with
them and then like the other people come
looking and it's like everybody ends up
hiding in the same spot till the last
person finds you oh what game is that
you guys I don't know it sounds like
sardines because you pack like sardines
yeah I was going to say I think it's
sardines another game that I think
really aged well cuz the last time we
played it at Camp toast it was so fun
tug of war
oh yeah that is just a classic game
Battle of brute strength right a a true
show of strength yeah it's the physics
of it could have been played in the
caveman era don't need much just a just
a rope yeah it's so simple I find the
best games are the simplest ones where
you don't need you know a whole balagon
with like equipment and gear you know
what you need tury your
imagination oh my God that's really
beautiful like for real it's so true so
true I missed those times where like my
imagination was enough it's not enough
now now I need like a cocktail my vape
by the way had some cocktails last night
did not Vape that's like honestly kind
of crazy that you're on a beach vacation
and not vaping and like and not in a
good way no I know and to be honest like
I am very much of the Mind where I'm
like okay if I have a cocktail or I'm
like you know cocktailing it up and
somebody has a vape like if I take a
puff it's like not a big deal yeah I
made the mistake of like bringing Ben in
on this journey with me because CU he's
being like a nut and he's like you can't
it will reset you and your addiction
like he's being so nuts like I kind of
wish I didn't get him involved and I
wanted to tell him to [__] all the way
off but he's like he's right you know
didn't I see him with a cigarette last
night that's the thing Ben's like but I
can control my addiction like I'm not
addicted to nicotine I just like Ben
like on vacation will smoke like two
cigarettes and he had one last night cuz
everybody else was smoking cigarettes
and that's so b s um so yeah like okay
Black Kettle pot
but he is right about the fact that he's
not addicted if you told him he was
never having another cigarette he
wouldn't even notice it's not like he's
like cigaret wait when he wakes up right
and with a vape I like especially for me
like it's a slippery slope like that's
how I started vaping like a cocktail and
a vape yeah yeah so no it's good what
you're doing cold turkey is really good
but like even I if I were on the trip
that you're on and like having come like
I would be vaping yeah it's a
celebration I'm here to celebrate my
friends birday VI all of like all these
people I know are coming from all over
the LA New York all over like it's a
c i want to enjoy and like if the
opportunity presents itself like I'm
just letting you know like I will be
taking a puff and everyone including Ben
can eat my [__] ass
respectfully and I'm letting you know I
Endor this decision and I as long as it
doesn't then set you back if you then go
back to like slippery slope then I'm
going to have to cut you off next time
but I am going to give you the
opportunity to show that I can do it a
social casual Vapor but you know what I
have heard cuz I once I opened up about
my journey so many people told me their
experiences which I found really helpful
a lot of the girlies were like I gave it
up it was the hardest thing did a cold
turkey like a lot of like whatever their
reasons were and then they said you know
the next time they like slipped up like
a few weeks later like it was disgusting
to them which would be so nice I don't
think that's going to happen to me also
I'm only 11 days they were saying like
after a month that
happened 11 days that's like not a lot
of days can you can by the way have
there ever been a longer 11 days days in
the lifetime of tury Lu freebush like I
can't no that means I was with you less
than 11 days ago yeah that's also
crazy that's really crazy how are the
stories today good varied um lots of
little cute good stories I feel okay
about them oh you know what I did last
night what I started the crown what
episode are you on I treated myself and
then of course I watched three episodes
and I was up super late but it actually
worked out because then I was still up
for Charlie's first feeding and I didn't
have to like fall asleep for 30 minutes
and then wake up which is harder Jackie
I believe I'm at the same did what
what's the thing that happened to Diana
just died same that's what I'm and I
just want to say I had one takeaway so
far you know I mean I have a lot of
thoughts but just the one thing that I'm
taking away is that I don't think enough
is made of the fact that Diana was
killed by a drunk driver not okay wait
not only that I'm so glad you said that
not only that because they're always
like the British media and the royal
family killed her two
she was in Paris so it was kind of the
French media and not the British media
right I guess you could say like media
in general and yeah the media hounded
her but they've been hounding her every
single day her since she got with
Charles yes this was a very heightened
time and Dodie and his like lackluster
security team were not up to the task
but every other time she like was
driving through the streets it's always
Mayhem and it was okay I just want to
say like I don't appreciate you putting
it on dod's security team like they kept
telling Dodie what to do and he would
not listen I'm sorry I didn't mean Dodie
I mean like Dodie security like the
security that he
yeah his umbrella not the the but he
needed more Security in the show and I
I'm I'm sure in terms of the actual
Logistics of the accident it might not
have happened that way but how they
showed it in the show was like at the
point where they went into that tunnel
and crashed like no one was around
them oh that's not what I got they were
being chased and they were driving fast
and it was a drunk driver and I they
just kind GL glossed over that a little
bit if it wasn't if the driver weren't
drunk there's a very good chance that
they wouldn't have crashed it just would
have been like typical Paparazzi Mayhem
car chase but he had been drinking he
was like glassy eyed and smiling weird
and being a they were supposed to spend
the night at The Ritz yeah so I feel
like not that's not as much of a
takeaway when it should be
like the more as much as like the media
needs to be held accountable like there
should also be like you know Mothers
Against Drunk Driving who are invested
in this story it's so
true so that was something that I found
interesting but other than that I've
been enjoying it and it's just it's nice
to have a a great show I agree and I'm
so glad that we're at the same point in
the show to to discuss yeah so now if
you had any thoughts you could share
them because we're
sympatico my thoughts
are developing obviously you know I'm
upset because last season my favorite
character was Muhammad fed um he was
hysterical and honestly like me if I
ever you know inherited billions of
dollars like exactly how we would spend
it like I I relate to him on on a human
level um now they're obviously like
pitting the whole thing on him like
everyone was stressed because of him and
everything went wrong because of him
like we to go to Paris because of him
the jet because of him so I don't like
love that but if that is how it happened
like I obviously can't
stand yeah I agree it's not he's in his
flop era for sure he's in his flop era
and like last season I just loved him
yeah no hilarious also I feel like you
could also put it on Dodie too cuz Dodie
was like I'm sorry when Dodie made the
phone call and hung up and then
continued to talk never in my life have
I felt so embarrassed for another human
being and the fact that like Diana knew
I was obsessed with that scene but then
I was looking by the way I in the first
three episodes I must have Googled like
10 things like a tale of two photographs
I looked up both of those phot I looked
the only thing I looked up was the boy
photograph yeah no it was like kind of a
loser photograph and stop then I just
started looking at pictures of Dodie
faed because like in the show he's an
unbelievable loser and like not someone
who could pull Princess Diana I'm sorry
in real life like he was hot like I feel
like they didn't do him Justice that's
that's not fair yeah yeah no he was like
he seemed like I mean it's just a
picture but he seemed like somebody who
could tell his own father off you know
he seems like strong and and oh not not
that I mean because you just never you
don't know what's on someone's insides
but I do feel like the fact that he was
not greatl looking in the show like
makes it so unbelievable that like him
and Diana would be together oh actually
the actor kind of looks like him sorry
it's a perfect casting oh that's
funny that is funny uh I had another
thought
about oh I mean who knows how it all
went down because like we don't know
what their private conversations were
like right before you know if he really
made that call and faked that call and
did he even buy the ring I feel like he
did because he showed it to someone in
the hotel suite and I'm sure like that
person is like came forward and was like
Dodie showed me a ring last night but I
just feel like what like if he really
wanted to land Diana like he could have
if he did other things different like
instead of like throwing her into chaos
or he even could have thrown her into
chaos and then be like I'm the only one
who can like protect you and and hired
so much security and like made her life
like so seamless and then she would be
like I don't have the protection of the
royal family like I need someone with
copious amounts of money for all this
security or else I can't even leave my
house and instead he just like kept
making things chaotic for her and she
was like why am I with this guy who is
chaotic even like a modly smart person
in his position could have gotten Diana
to fall in love with him or at least
make Diana feel like she needed him he
fumbled it so hard like how dumb are you
yeah yeah just like making everything
charged for her like when they went to
get ice cream and Monty Carlo like for
me that I got the I no by the way I
actually really related to that
sentiment of like her really wanting to
go home and then like having to go to
Paris and like it was just like we have
to get through the next like 24 hours
before I can just like get home and be
done with these people you know when
like you're on a trip or like you're
like almost like when you're like
remember when you used to have a play
dat and like you were so over this
[__] person you were having a play
dat with you're like I need to get home
like I need to be picked up so I can
never see this person again like that
feeling of just like needing to be home
wanting to be away from these people
starting to like [__] hate the people
around you I so resonated with that no
when like everybody wants a ride on a
private jet but like there's no such
thing as a free ride like right we're
just stopping in Paris we at the whims
of whatever the [__] they want to do and
you have like no she she was like how
did I get here you have no control you
can't be like pilot take me to he thr
right right right
so it's been enjoyable but now of course
she's passed so things are going to get
crazy but it was also kind of like a sad
time I mean it's always a sad time but
like she was at a really good place with
Charles Charles seems like he's in a
good place like the family just wants
the best R like the queen said like I
just want peace and of course we don't
know if these are direct quotes but that
is the vibe like she's out of the family
right you know I think everybody feels
sorry for her that her personal life is
like all over the papers like nobody
wants that for her and it's just like so
sad that that's how it ended
agreed
okay so with that breaking news from 30
years
ago here's the breaking news from today
love that in the fast five stories that
you need to know and the breaking news
from today in the fast five stories that
you need to know are brought to you by
the farmer's dog this new year the
easiest healthy Habit to start is one
for your dog the farmer's dog makes
feeding real healthy food easy and
convenient and your dog will absolutely
love it it's smart healthy pet food that
you can feel good about feeding your pup
and that's why it's time to quit the
kibble and kick the cans and start fresh
so the farmers dog is a company that
makes and delivers fresh healthy dog
food right to your front door it's
developed by vets it's nutritionally
balanced and it's made from real meat
and vegetables to the safety standards
of human food it's the best option for
dogs at all life stages because it's not
kibble it's not canned goo it's just
real healthy food traditional dry and
wet dog food options are super processed
they can use much lower quality
ingredients than they claim to and they
are extremely difficult to portion
accurately well the farmer's dog is
fresh high quality food but they're also
set the food pre-portioned specifically
for your dog based on their unique
nutritional needs so this will make it
easier to help maintain your dog's ideal
weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a full healthy life dogs
at a healthy weight can live up to 2 and
a half years longer than overweight dogs
a fresh diet has been found to have all
sorts of benefits from healthier coat
and skin better breath easier digestion
smaller better poops a healthy diet
isn't just important for humans so it
doesn't matter if your dog is young or
old it's always the right time to begin
investing in their health and that means
more happy healthy years together get
50% off of your your first box of fresh
healthy food at thefarmersdog.com toast
plus you'll get free shipping only when
you go to the farmers
dog.com toast to get that 50% off that's
thefarmersdog.com toast for free
shipping and 50% off today's episode is
also brought to you by Mattress Firm I
feel like it can't be you know
overstated how much the right mattress
matters and Mattress Firm will help you
find the right one mattress matters
Mattress Firm will find yours during
their once a year sale and clearance you
can score huge savings at Mattress Firm
and with their C Miss sale and their
clearance prices my bed is proudly from
Mattress Firm I just feel like
everybody's trying to reinvent like
mattresses when like the OG's Mattress
Firm is the spot my mattress I believe
the brand is temper Pedic and we got it
through mattress through Mattress Firm
they have a bunch of different brands
from all different
um price points whether you like
mattresses that come in the Box a lot of
people like those whether you like you
know I love temper Pedic um so you can
start your year off refreshed with great
rest for the year ahead make 20124 your
year of extraordinary sleep keep a
consistent
schedule and a a great mattress is a
great way to do that avoid late night
tossing turning with the mattress of
your dreams and get it during this once
a year sale and clearance restrictions
do apply but score huge savings at
Mattress Firm with can't miss sales and
clearance prices Mattress Firm is the
mattress place I mean it's literally in
the title all these different brands all
these different price points and a
couple times a year they have really
really good sales that you should take
ADV bandage of and this is one of it the
once a year sale and clearance you can
score huge savings at Mattress Firm with
the c Miss sale and clearance
prices um
[Music]
ready okay our first story Ari is back
with some new music she's firing back at
her critics in her new song yes and so
AR's long awaited I would say new music
is here title song yes and with an
accompanying music video and the message
of the song is kind of mind your own
beeswax she says your business is yours
and mine is mine why do you care so much
who's I ride who the yeah there's a lot
of like mind your own business why do
you care like stop looking at me like
say talk your talk say as somebody who
literally like talks about other
people's business for my line of work
like I do really agree with that
statement like General like just [__]
off like why do you care what I do like
I agree with the sentiment although I
don't follow that particular you know
religion um and in terms of the song
like I listened to it and I actually
didn't hear that lyric I didn't really
hear any of the lyrics I she's very like
whispery and breathy and I really liked
the song actually I just like I didn't
get the message because I had a hard
time like understanding the lyrics I
agree so the first time I listened to it
I liked the beat I didn't really know
what she was saying but I was enjoying
myself and then I watched the music
video with sub titles and there in I got
the message and so it's a lot of like
why do you care what I do and it's like
of course we care what you do for the
same reason you're putting out the song
is like the same reason why we care cuz
like you're a big star um but that's
fine if like that's her emmo and it did
kind of make me feel stupid for caring
so she accomplished what she said out to
accomplish I don't agree cuz if she was
just like dating some guy and people
were like rioting or mad what like those
people are [__] losers it's giving
like gelina but with this you know most
recent relationship there is like an
ethical issue like thing I have an I
take issue with and that's why I feel
like everybody cares more than they
usually
care yeah but crazy she did but there
was also some messaging of like you
don't know this whole story sort of
thing which like to say okay I'm going
to read the lyrics okay but before you
do I just want to say she is following
this sort of formula from thank you next
where she samples like a really
well-known song Like My Favorite Things
was thank you next and this is um Vogue
um I was going to say it sounds like
Vogue yeah no she sampled it and then
she has this like kind of kitchy cute
phrase yes and thank you next it's like
a formula that works for her with a
great music video and we'll see if it
works a second time but like lightning
struck the first time like she'll never
really be able to recreate like what
thank you next did for the culture do
you remember that it was like every day
she was breaking a Spotify record I
remember like sitting on your couch
babysitting rest in peace Theo and he
and I were watching the live countown to
watch the music video for that song W
I'm so glad Theo lived to see that yeah
I remember where I was and I think it's
a really good formula I think this is a
strong song not nearly as exciting of a
music video but a little more artistic
but I think like this song won't reach
the levels that thank you next did but
it's a fire Bop and I think it'll do
well and very respectable showing from
Miss Ari I agree here are the lyrics so
we can know like this is what's on AR's
heart yeah because honestly I I
literally don't even I don't know any of
the lyrics so sing them to me in case
you haven't noticed Well everybody's
tired and healing from somebody or
something we don't see just right so
she's kind of saying like everybody's
going through their own [__] like in
case you didn't know okay boy come on
put your lipstick on no one can tell you
nothing come on and Walk This Way
Through the Fire don't care what's on
their mind and if you find yourself in a
dark situation just turn on your light
and be like so this is like the message
of the song coming up yes and say that
[__] with your chest and be your own
[__] best friend say that [__] with
your chest keep moving like what next
yes and so there it is I I do feel like
it's probably for the best that I
couldn't understand the lyrics because
like I agree what you just read sounds
really dumb but like I'm it like popped
off in the song you know yeah but also a
sign of a good song is that I already
have I already know the melody yes and
say that [__] with your chest get it
Jack and be your own [__]
best friend say that [__] with your
chest keep moving like what's next
oh jar on the grande if a songwriter
brought me these lyrics I would say you
need a new job I would say You're Fired
yeah but like it's the beat it's music
and lyrics right no it's more so like
the beat especially with this particular
song so it's nice to have Ari back in
the fold of like you know pop girly
icons and she said now I'm so done with
caring what you think no I won't hide
underneath your own projections or
change my most authentic life
okay I mean it's just kind of like a
brave thing to say like when you
literally stole a married man from like
his newborn child his 10-month old baby
yeah yeah so there so if there is more
to the story like I I think we need to
know it like for real cuz she's now
accusing us of being like losers who are
like you know speculating whatever but
it's like based on what we know like
what you did was crazy so if it's if
there's more of the story like let us
know but I just want to say like as a
strategy of course this whole
relationship kind of blew up and people
were mad at Ari and she could have gone
a number of different ways and the
strategy of doubling down and being like
yes and I find to be a very strong one
and I respect it I don't dislike it I
agree with that you know cuz what's done
is done at least she's still with him
like some Scandal version she would have
broken up with him and like you know
been the victim she's like no I did that
[__] yes and yes and yeah no I I do for
sure but you know let's we not forget
the ethical dilemma that Li that lies
within this
Saga yes but let's we not forget that we
don't know these people and it's their
lives not ours yes and and and say that
[__] with your chest and and be your own
[__] best when I go to the beach
after this like I'll put in my airpods
and I'll like see see how it how it
Vibes on a beach and I'll report back I
think it holds up I'm sure it does Ari
doesn't put out bad music like you could
say what you want about her she's a
talented vocalist obviously but like her
music pop like she pops her [__] like
she puts her whole arusi in that
sometimes you know do do you watch the
music video I didn't I didn't even know
she released one um I'm in Mexico I
don't know if I um I'm like on this
international trip so I don't know if I
have like access to the music video here
I'm sure you do if we could do a podcast
no no no it's like I'm I'm on like this
really remote like Elite part of
Mexico are you ready for our next story
yes okay usually I don't like talking
about like reality TV show news if I
haven't watched it yet but this was
crazy enough that we must discuss so
Southern Charm reunion aired last night
and Olivia flowers admitted to hooking
up with Thomas
Ravenel right and so in the uh Playbook
of what's currently going on this season
Olivia was like dating in love with
Austin and then she got really mad at
her best friend Taylor who slept with
Austin yeah it's not as that as that
because first of all even last season
like Olivia and Austin were like a thing
will they won't they but I don't know
that they were ever like fully boyfriend
girlfriend and in love like yeah by the
way I watched the beginning of last
season so I don't know how it progressed
but what I remember is that like she
really liked him and we didn't even know
if he liked her back No and it was like
they both liked each other but they just
like couldn't get together and also
Austin likes everyone so true I never
saw their relationship as that serious
then they filmed their re the Southern
Charm reunion in in New York and I think
they had tried to make a go of it and
then they like were like you know what
we're done for we're not this isn't
happening I think Austin ended things
with her even though there wasn't much
to end but still he was the one who
decided no and she went to LA for a
little bit to like take some time for
herself meanwhile Taylor Anne who is
Shep's ex-girlfriend at the time and
Olivia's best best friend on the show is
also very good friends with Austin and I
guess they hooked up during that time
that she was in LA and then it's all
coming out this season and I think
things were looking like Olivia might
forgive her because Taylor just seems
really genuine even though she keeps
[__] up like she's just like she
can't well she did lie she can't get out
of her own way almost no it's just it's
a very weird I've never felt this way
about someone who it's like I'm rooting
for them and I believe them but they
just like keep doing not the best things
and keep lying about it now explain to
me Thomas Ravenel okay no actually
explain to me like Catherine's
relationship to Olivia like do they have
any sort of loyalty towards another yes
so they're very good friends from the
show and so at the reunion last night it
seems like in her own defense s how did
it come
to the to come to light that she hooked
up at Thomas did somebody out her did
she say it yes yes so at the reunion
she's going Olivia's going in on Taylor
for you know sleeping with Austin and
then Taylor said forgive as you would
want to be forgiven and everyone was
like what do you mean by that and Olivia
was like go ahead and say it I already
see what you're trying to do you been
hanging this over you've been hanging
this over my head I want to see it say
it say it and Andy Andy was like well
just say it like we're here and Taylor
said the whole Thomas situation and Andy
was like everybody just like audibly
gasp like E I didn't watch it yet but
the how all these like beautiful smart
sophisticated young women like keep
sleeping with Thomas Ravenel he's not
only is he like you know has allegations
of sexual abuse like he's literally not
even handsome
well this is what Olivia said she said
quote I was fresh out of college 20
years old dumb dumb drunken night one
time had a hookup with tev and I wanted
to take it to my grave who wouldn't oh
I'm sorry so it wasn't recent no it was
about 10 years ago cuz I think Olivia
around so Taylor an is like you know cuz
Olivia is very good friends with
Catherine and has never told Catherine
about this but Olivia is like I hooked
up with Thomas before I ever met
Catherine I'm sorry was was 10 years ago
before her kids were born like before
Catherine and no she uh they said it was
a like they already had two kids by then
but her son isn't 10 right so maybe it
wasn't 10 years ago maybe it was like
six but I thought Olivia is like 30
anyways it's not Apples to Apples cuz
Olivia wasn't friends with Katherine but
Olivia's friends with Katherine now and
has never told her meanwhile last night
deal last night Katherine posted on
Instagram pictures with Olivia being
like I love you good okay actually now
it feels like this was brought up like
like Taylor's a bad faith actor like
it's not really relevant I'm sorry I
thought it was like this week they they
[__] or like you know like this year
no it was like something embarrassing
that Olivia and and and she only told
Taylor her friend and now Taylor told
everyone it's like that is just wrong oh
I'm sorry okay I'm now that I understand
like the
full um like I would literally never
talk to this person again if like there
was somebody I hooked up with who I was
so embarrassed about and like I
literally never told anyone and like and
I wasn't hurting anyone by not telling
anyone like I just needed to take this
to my grave forever like and you then
tell it on TV like not only do I hate
you like I am so [__] done with you
that's actually like a a whole other
level of betrayal I agree and I just
don't know why Taylor Anne keeps doing
bad things no and Jackie and honestly
this doesn't serve Taylor Anne at all
because it doesn't make Olivia look bad
this was before she knew Catherine like
Katherine has been posting with Olivia
so it's all good so she really did this
horrible thing tailor she didn't really
make a point she didn't really you know
slay the argument she just looks like a
vengeful like spiteful person and
honestly not that I ever planned on it
but I will never tell this girl a secret
of mine like if I meet her I'm running
the other way yeah the the Taylor had
said it was five years ago but I think
that might be murky of when it was but
definitely before Olivia ever met
Catherine
damn that's really like the way I
internalize the story once you first
said it and now that I know everything
is so different yeah like again is the
victim yeah
and Taylor an like she needs to she
needs to stop
and and maybe reality TV is not the best
thing for her because before she met CHP
and before she came into this world she
was just like a nice girl a nice girl
she's very religious and she just like
she's she's not practicing what she
preaches is how I feel and it's
disappointing I really like her this is
like Fame and like the toxicity of
reality TV like really I think based on
what you're
saying turning someone into like the
worst version of themselves yeah even
though like a part of me and I'm not
even so mad about the Austin thing
because a part of me feels like Taylor
an and Austin like are made for each
other because they're really good
friends and maybe they should be
together and I'm not mad at them for
exploring that especially because I
never felt like Olivia and Austin's
relationship was that serious but it was
the lying she was literally lying
straight to everyone's face she sounds
like truly diabolical and it feels like
it's one of those situations cuz now
that I've heard you talk about like your
take on Southern Charm for like the last
couple of weeks SL months like I feel
like you just like her and you're like
looking for ways to defend her but like
she maybe is not worth your defenses no
this is kind of the last draw for me but
I do need to finish watching the season
not the last not sometimes by the way
and I understand this like when you
really ride for someone but like
sometimes you need to know like when The
Jig Is up and I think like your Jig Is
up yeah cuz this yeah I like to give
chances I'm you know we're all human of
course we make mistakes but she
literally made another mistake last
night after like a couple years of
making mistakes like you've got to at
some point stop of
course so I need to catch up on Southern
Charm after I finish the crown but now
that I've turned my TV back on
anything's possible you know the the
world is truly your oyster I know but
then I was like up so late watching TV I
know I know it's like what are you 16
like whenever I'm up like sleep whenever
I'm up past midnight like watching a TV
show that I just can't put down um I
literally feel like literally I'm in
high school and I'm going get in trouble
like if my mom comes in and like the
remote like I keep the remote in my hand
to like turn it off in case she comes in
like
I I understand that feeling and it's
also like we're business owners we're
women we're mothers it's like what are
we doing staying up all night watching
television yeah I guess last night I
felt like I could do it because we were
recording a little later today and it's
audio only so I could sleep in if I
needed to true and it's Friday so it's
it's very LAX over here it's like it's
kind of a casual Friday at the toast
Sunday night I'm up really late and I
have like a full day like today's kind
of a relaxed day for me so I was like oh
I'll be a little crazy stay up late love
that you deserve you know and look and
look I can't stop talking about it so
maybe it was very good for me right no
it was F you were actually like doing
the work because it's f for the show
that's always the truth yeah no when
you're a podcaster that like podcasts
about your own life you can really kind
of make any poor decision about work
like you can say like I had to do that
like I had to get so drunk like for the
story so I can tell them on the podcast
yeah but that's how you get to be living
like a life that you don't want to be
living no like a life that's not yours
yeah like when you're just doing
everything for the story just in general
I feel like non-p podcasters do that
people do that so that they could tell
their friends something crazy and it's
like okay but you still had to like do
something crazy and how did that make
you feel yes
and yes and are you ready for our next
story what number is it three yes
Jessica Simpson is poking fun at her
viral chicken mixup in a new ad with her
daughter Max so 20 years on Jessica
Simpson is poking fun at her chick
Chicken of the Sea moment in a new ad
for the tuna brand in the clip she's
sitting on the couch with her daughter
Maxi while eating from a packet of tuna
her daughter says Mom what are you
eating in the package she said it's
called chicken of the sea but it's not
really chicken so don't get confused by
it her daughter says who would and
Jessica's like yeah who would not me no
by the way I have so many thoughts from
this one Love The Association I can't
believe these these two never worked
together and by two I mean chicken of
the sea
and Jessica Simpson until this moment I
loved like the younger generation
element Jessica Simpson's like a really
good actress I thought that like she
acted really well in the commercial I do
want to say
something
oh and it's something that I guess one
could say is in defense of Jessica
Simpson's intellect why the [__] is it
called chicken of the
sea
what would you like to
say did you not hear what I said no you
cut out oh sorry okay why the [__] is it
called Chicken of the Sea like why the
[__] would a tuna company have in its
brand name chicken that's like the toast
which is
a digital show digital being called like
the cable but we're on digital like it
makes no [__] sense
yeah well I think they're trying to they
were trying to and maybe they were
successful because it feels this way now
they were trying to like normalize
tuna you know yeah because people eat
chicken and it maybe tuna gives people
the Willies especially like from a can
or a packet but if it's oh it's the
chicken okay okay but also like do
people eat chicken of the sea like I
know everybody loves like there's a
couple like classic grocery store
companies and I feel like chicken of a
sea is like not one of like the big ones
I think it is but there's the other one
the one is it like
starfish
circus yeah but I'm not going to lie she
was eating this packet of tuna wild
caught light tuna that's lemon garlic
flavored by McCormick that's like what
she was eating on the couch and that
sounds fire Jackie that's like a
commercial working and I actually think
you should buy and do a taste test on
your Instagram and Ben too Ben is very
very very very he won't eat star kiss
like he doesn't think it's good enough
he does like wild cot from this company
he like has to get a special um he's not
like an ordinary tuna a consumer okay
but when we were on vacation he had tuna
in cans from the store and he made tuna
fish like every day so he had tuna in
cans I don't believe it was starus I
think it was his special
company oh it's like a yellow and blue
let me look look it up I'll tell you
exactly because I feel like people will
actually want to know tuna Can
wild wild planet is that it let me just
look yes Wild
Planet and like when you look when you
want to buy it online like you buy it at
herb.com herbspro do.com it's like weird
eBay it's been selling his old tuna no
it literally is so I have to exclude Ben
from this conversation is what I'm
saying because he's not like your
typical consumer when it comes to tuna
got it well the packet looks really good
and then in the end of the commercial
she's holding a packet that looks like
it was seasoned with like some Thai
flavorings and they're doing like
collabs cuz like McCormick lent its
flavors to the tuna anyways all in all
10 out of 10 10 out of 10 marketing 10
out of 10 production Jessica's
performance was a 10 out of 10 love her
getting her daughter involved getting
her in the SAG you know um I love this
and I really feel like if you would have
asked me the day before yesterday like
is chicken of the sea still in business
I honestly would have said I don't know
now I
know yeah I no I would have said yes you
knew that yeah okay yeah and didn't they
do chicken of the sea ads on The
Apprentice
The Apprentice yeah when Joan was on
remember that was one of their
challenges and she made up that jingle
cluck cluck cluck Splat okay okay yeah
yeah yeah I didn't realize you were
referencing like we were trying to see
if chicken of the sea is still relevant
and I didn't see how you bring up a TV
show that aired 11 years ago would be
helpful in this relevant conversation
well they made it till 11 years ago so
like you know halfway there
cool yeah do you remember that episode
I don't really I also don't remember a
lot of when we sat down to watch Joan
Rivers on Celebrity Apprentice and I
think I need to rewatch it again because
I know she but she spoiler alert ends up
winning um but there was a lot of
Dynamics at play you know she came on
with her daughter and her daughter like
stunk it up because her daughter just
like couldn't Jive the way the and
compete the way Joan could Joan was also
like a lot older than a lot of these
people but I know that the Joan that we
knew when she passed away like that
level of Fame was really like the
Catalyst for that level that she reached
was her winning Celebrity Apprentice
It's like a really important part of her
career so if you are like a scholar of
Joan Rivers which we like to consider
ourselves like it's actually it's
required viewing that you watch that
season it is and it's so good there are
so many Dynamics at play like her and
Annie Duke Annie Duke yeah so her and
Annie Duke have this like really crazy
rivalry Annie Duke is a professional
poker player if you don't know who she
is and she's really major um but also
other celebrity dynamics that are at
play during that season that are really
interesting Khloe Kardashian she was
actually kicked off because she had to
miss a challenge to go to a court
hearing for her DUI and when Donald
Trump found out that she was uh that she
had had a DUI that she was a person who
drunk drove he was like you're out of
here I don't Vibe with that then Jesse
James who now we know is like disgraced
former husband of Sandra Bullock we know
the Kat Von D scandal at the time he was
Sandra Bullock's husband there is a lot
going on in that season like it's really
worth your time
it is worth your time he was a sleeper
candidate he performed really well I
actually ended up really liking him
after that yeah then there was Dennis
Rodman of course he was really really
really unhinged and like honestly he
really bothered me and I think my My
overall feelings towards him went down
be due to his performance on Celebrity
prenant he he really thought he was like
too good for the whole thing yeah you
know who bothered me who Brandy Andrew
Dice Clay oh my God Andrew Dice Clay
bothered me
yes and you know who else bothered me
who Tom
Green oh okay so Tom Green yes first of
all Tom Green like came into the show
and was like I'm a loser and I'm going
to give off loser energy he gave off
such like woe is me energy like oh my
God I completely agree like not that I
really had a high opinion of Tom Green
before because I don't not really
familiar with him but after that season
I was like oh you're a loser
yeah and you know who is also on the
season Claudia Jordan who then
afterwards yes was on Real Housewives of
Atlanta she had a very strong showing on
the season I agree I liked her after
that and who I loved from the season was
Brandy she was the Playboy bunny I
forget her last name I want to say
Redmond but obviously but it's not and I
want to say Glennville and it's not
either but it's similar to both of those
she was also a very strong participant
it's such a good season it's actually a
very good show that's the only only
season that I watch because of Joan but
I kind of want to watch other Seasons
speaking of it's like a lot of
Housewives wind up like I know Kyle did
it theres yeah like they get really good
they got really good people by the way
speaking of hold on wait what did you
just say before Claudia Jordan yes sweet
Brandy Redmond Glenville speaking of
Brandy
Redmond I ended up on a Stephanie Holman
rabbit hole because she's been like
going viral on Tik Tok she's been like
answering questions like as a former
housewife like about like production
stuff but also like keeping then I
started like keeping up with her life
she just moved into this like insane
house in
Oklahoma oh okay and I just feel like
while the whe houses of Dallas didn't
work out and I do feel like it wasn't
amazing but I don't think they got like
a completely fair chance there were some
some perfect housewives on that show and
Stephanie Holman was one of them like I
need her to move to a city that has a
franchise like she should be on TV yeah
wescot too Cameron Wescott both of them
like their lives are just ripe for
reality TV like so much money so many
houses fabulous bags all this stuff and
I I like need that I need that sort of
energy I agree like it wasn't always the
best franchise but they it wasn't the
worst like it was fine I feel like just
Housewives was going through a lull and
Bravo needed to make a cut and so they
cut Dallas but she was saying in her
stories like because so many of the
questions were about cast trip she was
like we had like no budget if you really
think about it our first cast trip we
went to me and bry's house in Austin our
lake house at one point we went to
Caracus in Carrie brittingham's house
like they were always going to someone's
house then they took that trip to
Colorado in Cameron westcott's house
right she was like when we got to go to
where did they go
Ireland no the
Netherlands yeah because Carrie duck was
oh and that's when uh the was talking
about her panty liner she said that was
like the biggest deal for us like we
finally got a trip that wasn't like
$4 I thought they also went to Thailand
though later on yes they did you're
right you're right you're right did she
mention that but they also had piggy
backed on something trash was doing
there so maybe it really was like she
didn't mention Thailand she mentioned
that like the Netherlands was a really
big deal for
them happy for them
yeah are you ready for our next story
now number four only if it's our next
story that's brought to you by Lumi if
you want a New Year's resolution that
won't have you Tangled in an elliptical
or eating the world's most depressing
salad try smelling better naked Lumi is
a game-changing whole body deodorant
designed by an OBG to work not only on
pits but also feet privates and
everywhere else that we get odor so no
matter where you use it Lumi is
clinically proven to block odor all day
long thanks to its one-of aind pH
optimized formula and they've got over
275,000 f-star reviews to show for it
make the switch to Lumi and this year
will be all about head to- toe
confidence no salads required I'm so
glad somebody's talking about body odor
that like is in your armpits because of
course armpits are of utmost concern but
like there's a lot going on in the body
like and there are a lot of places that
could you know require your attention
when it comes to odor removal and I love
that Lumi is is all about whole body
deodorizing it's safe to use anywhere on
your body so that includes your pits
your under boobs your thigh folds belly
button belly buttle butt crack vulvas
feet it's created by an OBGYN so she saw
how normal boo was being misdiagnosed
and mistreated it's clinically proven to
block odor all day and control odor for
up to 72 hours it's baking soda free
it's paraben free it's ph balanced for
safe use in the nether regions and it's
clinically proven to control odor better
than a shower with soap alone so special
offer for you guys new customers can get
$5 off at lum's starter pack with the
exclusive code and Link the code is
toast at lumid deodorant.com that's l m
deodorant Deo do nt.com lumid
deodorant.com code
toast thank you la you're welcome our
next story is some exciting Fitness news
oh my God exciting can Fitness news be
exciting yes because jelly roll is
training for his first
5k and it's actually very star studded
5K so jelly roll has started training
For an upcoming 5K saying I'm in the
woods walking every morning he shared an
Instagram post on Thursday as he went
for his morning walk saying that he
decided to work towards the 5K after
appearing on the full send podcast the
podcast host Kyle Gast him up jelly roll
says to join forces with Comics Bert
Cher and Tom seura who are Rec
recruiting participants For an upcoming
5K in May so Bert crer and Tom saguro do
the two bears one cave podcast we're
always you know sitting amongst them in
the comedy charts and they said on their
show that's our New Year's resolution
let's get ready for it let's train for
their recruiting fellow Comics to do
this 5K with them like Michelle wolf and
stavos house WF Michelle wolf and l k
louisy k gave them attentive yes to join
their 5K and then jelly roll is getting
Zach Bryan to join this 5K so like kind
of everyone's doing a 5K okay okay so
here's the thing Tom suur and bird crer
I'll do your 5K like I'm a comic I am
like able to walk now without like
vomiting I I think by may like how how
many miles is a 5K it's like one and a
half it's like it's really not a lot
right like a 5k I know like sounds like
a lot cuz they put it in the metric
system but it's lowkey like a couple
feet yeah no I did a 5k once and it
wasn't like I had to train or anything
but I I guess I was a fit person so how
long
isense 3.1 miles okay lowkey that's like
kind of a lot that's like 60 blocks okay
so Bert Tom if you hear this message
feel free to reach out I will do it is
it for charity like are we donating
money or is it just like I'm sure there
is probably a charitable component but I
think it just started as like a
inspirational aspirational thing that
they were doing it's their New Year's
resolution yeah no I read Tom sagur you
told me to read Tom sigur's book I
didn't finish it but a lot of it was
like about weight I related to that like
sentiment of just like being fat yeah
and I know that nobody asked us like if
we want to do this star studded
podcast podcasters who run yeah I think
that we should do it yeah please reach
out um but as long as like we're you
know in the podcaster suite oh yeah no
and like I feel okay so like obviously
like all the comedy guys in the charts
like they know each other they do each
other's show and we're just kind of
these like two fat [__] like right up
there with them and like they don't know
us we don't know them we like never DM
or anything like I feel like definitely
left out of that like you know it's
that's what they say it's a boys club
yeah it's true but no Tim Dylan Tim
Dylan throws us a bone he throws us
bones yeah he's the only one that has
included Us in like the boys club but
like the other people know each other on
a personal level like not just from the
charts like there really is no way for
us to get in until this 5K which seems
like a meeting of the podcasters it
sounds like all the podcasters in the
comedy section are meeting up and they
haven't invited us and I will not
[__] stand for that okay so if I have
to run three mil just to get some
attention I'll do it yeah and you know
what I was going to say that the only
other podcaster who's like not one of
those boys in the comedy charts who's
like on the comedy charts with us is the
dumb blonde podcast but that's jelly
roll's wife jelly roll's wife so she'll
be there too oh wait also speaking of
jelly roll and when you brought him up I
thought that's what you were going to be
talking about today he testified before
Congress yesterday about fenol oh yeah
that was important but I do think the 5K
was more no right like I was like oh
okay I guess we're picking this like
less relevant K story um he spoke really
beautifully and I just like love
him yeah you know what but like I I'll
take that on the chin that I prioritize
chose wrong story jelly k over jelly
null but it's what was headline news
really cuz I didn't even see the thing
about the 5K and I saw the fenol thing
like everywhere and honestly like good
for him for using his platform like
that's like an actually like a serious
[__] issue yeah no I agree I'm making
jokes but like good for him for using
his platform and that's important work
and we should be supporting it and by
way he said he's like I'm before I speak
like I realize like me being here like a
former drug dealer is like insane for me
to be testifying at Congress but for so
many years I was a part of the problem
and now I want to be a part of the
solution like I literally had chills it
was so good so good it seems like he's
making a lot of changes in the new year
yeah I and that's the other thing cuz I
watch his documentary he's an addict and
the way he sort of like living with his
addiction is he's not totally sober but
he doesn't really do hard drugs anymore
he smokes pot and he drinks a lot but
he's like I've traded a lot of my
addictions for food addiction and that's
how he said he got to the weight that he
was at he was very very open about that
um and so like a 5k is great I love that
by the way now that like I'm like put it
out there like I really don't want to
run this 5K cuz I'm just thinking about
how like anytime I've ever been on the
treadmill like it literally takes me 30
minutes to run a mile that's fine cuz
you could run and walk and it's going to
be like a social thing so we could just
like walk in chat speed walk you know
there's no rush it's just about comple
it's about friendship andar and the
bonds we've made it's not about the
destination it's about the journey yeah
and I think it would be good for our
careers well that's really like just to
be abundantly clear like if we get
invited to this 5K and it's for charity
like we will donate like we will do what
we need to do but I'm only doing it for
self- serving reasons like I just want
that to and like to meet some of my
heroes yeah of course like it's about
it's high time we met Tim
Dylan yeah and Tom seura sigura
and hopefully hopefully his wife
Christina P hopefully she'll be there in
her mom jeans well she's another top 10
comedic podcaster so of course she will
and her husband's and her husband's
organizing the no and also where is it
like where are we committing to
going I just feel like this I didn't see
this but I just feel like it's in Austin
because that's where okay I love a trip
to Austin I'm so
down yeah and that's where kind of all
the comedic podcasters live maybe if we
moved to Austin like then we could be in
this circle ofic podcast I was just
going to say like us not living in
Austin is like bad for our careers
agreed and you know who's probably gonna
be there too then let me think Lauren
bosik no wait maybe no it's like so
obvious Jo Joe Rogan we have to get
invited to this SP
guy we have to
go maybe if we put it in the title of
the
episode oh my God oh my God no literally
Bert and Tom col call
us that's what we're doing okay we're
using our platform for good good no by
the way like they should have a
charitable element to this so like maybe
I don't know I'm sure they do I don't
think you can organize a 5k with like no
I don't think they do 5Ks that literally
don't benefit charity I've never seen a
5k that didn't benefit a charity like
then what are you doing yeah
totally cool are you ready for our fifth
and Final story which is some sports
news some sports news yeah there was
kind of some big sports news that
happened so this is like kind of Bill
bellich is leaving the Patriots and a
new coach has been named Jared Mayo
who's 37 and he's the youngest coach in
NFL history now that Bill bich is
leaving the Patriots after six Super
Bowls in 65 years and just lot of
history yeah um and the last time
he was at the last game he was at he
like left the field with his head down
cuz they lost like by a million points
and I think everybody knew like was
there was rumors that it was going to be
his last game um and does that mean he's
retiring or he's going to another
team I think retiring because one you
know he's of that age and two if he
wanted to still be a coach like why
would he after 65 years go somewhere
else like
65 yeah no he's 65 years old I'm sorry
I'm
sorry
30 right 30 okay glad we cleared that up
um and did you say this was like a
two-part Sports
story
24 okay thank you it's becoming less and
less impressive yeah it is a two-part
story because they just named their new
head coach who is Jared mayo and he's
the youngest coach in NF g e r o d Mayo
like Helman and he's the youngest coach
in NFL history and he's the first black
coach in New England's 65 year history
it's Jared with a J not
g I didn't say G did you literally said
g okay go back and Rewind the S they're
so similar he's so
cute what's his age if you were born in
19 37 oh that's really young that's what
I'm saying that's why it's a two-part
story and say that again he's the first
black coach for the Patriots Yeah
obsessed by Bill like honestly I've
never been like a big like I'm not
really into the coaches although I do
think the coach of the Eagles is so cute
what is his
name yeah Phil Nick serani yes I also
love Andy
Reid yeah he's a cutie and then there
was that coach of the Jets whose name
was
Rex and Rex Ryan and he looks like my
father-in-law and like I could not get
over it but then I found out he had a
brother
who was also a coach and it was just
like such a cute the Rex Ryan
brother Rob
Ryan they both look like Bruce offer
Jackie like it's crazy I'm going to go
look up Rex Ryan but then there was that
other coach of the Jets I mean Rex ran
was a while
ago who is the Jets there was another
one who's like a big name he's always
getting into
trouble oh okay the Jets coach now
Robert Sal hot hot bald not who it bald
and
hot I just have the idea of someone in
my
head and I'm not going to be able to
tell you who I'm thinking of I mean like
us trying to talk about football coaches
when we can barely like keep the players
like the coaches is a whole another I
know a whole another thing but but you
know what ain't it good to be the
coach I'm sure it is and hopefully
Gerard will be finding out soon love
that Bye Bill
yeah bye bill but like thank you for
your service six Super Bowls amazing
tenure great work job well done not us
doing like such a banger 1hour episode
on a Friday when I'm on vacation like I
thought this was going to be like a
40-minute piece of [__] but like this is
so like we even when we don't try like
we are so supremely
talented yeah that we're in the right
industry and it's high time that Bert
and Tom recognize that yeah it's high
time that we ascended to
the meetings of the top 10 comedic
podcasters so title we're thinking Bert
and Tom colon call us or like two guy
two two
bears two bears one toast like how will
we get their
attention bird and Tom call us okay but
like like how many birts and toms are
there you know what I mean they'll know
like if they title their episode Jackson
tur call us like oh my God I would die
yeah also I could just see them like not
giving a rip about the podcast charts
and never seeing our title what's that
like I don't believe that there are
people who put content out who don't
vigorously refresh the charts like I
mean I guess like no like no sorry
there's no way no and also it's
irresponsible to do that because you
need to know like where like if you're
if people liked this guest how things
are performing like you know you can't
just like put things out like you're
running a business you need to know what
the feedback
is per
so that is our last show of the week and
also our last show until Tuesday Monday
is Martin Luther King day so there will
not be an episode of the toast so just
keep that in mind thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast that
Millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so it's Spotify iTunes
Stitcher public radio I Radio cast box
all the places where you listen to
podcast find us the toast five star
about a beautiful standing and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you on Tuesday
bye love you bye
um